r est déjà là les collections de prêt à
porter font en ce moment de parier et ce
jusqu'au 29 mars
la capitale mondiale de la mode tous les
acheteurs étrangers sont là pour
découvrir ce que les créateurs ont
inventé pour l'hiver prochain france rof
shedden loustallot nous en révèle allure
vous vous demandiez ce qui se trouvait
sous le chapeau de tôle surmontant le
louvre et bien voilà à l'intérieur se
trouvent les chantiers du futur musée de
la mode c'est encore un peu désordre
mais jean charles de castelbajac sonia
rykiel yves saint laurent et d'autres
célébrités de la couture ont risqué leur
peau et leurs vêtements griffés pouvoir
où se trouvera dans quelques mois le
palais où seront conservés leurs
créations
ladsous un immense escalier hélicoïdal
permettra de rêver devant la robe du
soir d'une présidente ou la combinaison
cape d'une extrême avant que la mode
n'est sa maison au pique nique en forme
de marathon non loin de là au jardin des
tuileries en présence de spécialistes du
vêtement harnachés en costume de nonnes
de poupées de foire de cartomancienne ou
le veulent le prêt à porter de la mode
divers 84 85 des fils
sachez donc qu'il faudra absolument
s'alléger parfois trop large fini les
complexes quand on prendre un kilo toof
leurs travaux les tracas chat du moins
si on en croit la styliste japonaise de
comme des garçons
c'est une image mi temps qu'ils sont
tous étaient quelque chose
johnny rep éléments intérieurs
et complètement
mail personnel ça c'est sûr yugo koshino
propose lui des chapeaux flèche à moins
que ce ne soit des chapeaux grille quand
on veut se protéger d'un assaut les
faits et sûrement foudroyant si on aime
les câlins ça complique mais les robes
de vos singes et les enroulements de
bandelettes prête à plus de séduction
freinage j'aime bien les bêtes avec
thomas jane peu après histoire l'homme
bérenger aime le style mécano en deuil
ni aviateurs me euros ces couleurs tout
un programme
terre brume volcan galets et asphalte
ses manteaux sont déchiquetés et super
en plomb pourraient y abriter facilement
deux bergers
sa flotte toujours ça ne sert pas course
ce qu'on va être bien l'hiver prochain
si on n'a pas peur des coins d'air
et